Das Chaos Radio, eine Sendung über technische Systeme, die nicht immer so funktionieren, wie sie sollen, ist dieses Mal Opfer eines technischen Systems geworden, das nicht so funktioniert hat, wie es soll. Falls euer Ohr also an ein paar Aussetzern oder unvollständigen Sätzen hängen bleibt, bitten wir vielmals um Entschuldigung. Nächstes Mal wird es bestimmt wieder besser. Oder wir entdecken dann einen anderen spannenden Fehler. Jetzt aber viel Spaß beim Chaos Radio 266. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 266, wo wir uns damit beschäftigen, warum euer Gesicht und seine Datenrepräsentation auch in Zukunft euch gehören soll. Wir sprechen heute über Reclaim the Face, beziehungsweise Gesichtserkennung stoppen, eine Initiative eben genau dafür, um Gesichtserkennung zu stoppen. Und was dahintersteckt, was Biometrie dazu mit zu tun hat, was man jetzt gerade politisch dagegen tut und wie das alles zusammenhängt, dafür habe ich heute sehr viele Gäste da und begrüße recht herzlich in der Reihenfolge, wie sie im Patch stehen. Du bist beim Forum Informatikerinnen für Frieden und gesellschaftliche Verantwortung und machst ansonsten noch was?
Aber das heißt, ich habe ja gerade gefragt, nachdem sozusagen passiert... Also ich finde es nicht...
Ich finde es nicht grundsätzlich abzulehnen. Das wäre für mich nicht der Punkt. Aber in sowas wie öffentlichen Plätzen, wo staatliche oder auch Firmen das sozusagen auf so eine Art zentralisierte Art und Weise sammeln und auswerten und so weiter, da entsteht der große Unterschied. Das ist dann für mich der Punkt.
Aber die Antwort auf meine Frage ist dann, ja, das kann man schon mal machen.
Ich finde, das kann man schon mal machen, ja. Also es ist so ein Punkt. Wenn die Menschen tatsächlich eine echte Wahl haben, dann finde ich es okay. Aber man muss immer die Rahmenbedingungen auch betrachten. Haben sie wirklich eine Wahl oder wissen sie die? Was eben gesagt worden ist, kennen sie die Risiken nicht? Und können sie die überhaupt kennen?
Ich freu mich jetzt schon, das war ja die Prämisse meiner Frage. Und du sagst es trotzdem noch mal so ausführlich. Ist das so, weil deine Erfahrungen damit sind, dass das eigentlich nicht der Fall ist?
Dass die Leute sich da nicht auskennen? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Wir haben ja gehört, es ist ja wie bei allen Datenschutzfragen, die größte Lüge des Internet ist die informierte Einwilligung. Also ist ja auch okay in einer arbeitsteiligen Gesellschaft. Das hat ja Anke sehr schön erklärt, wie auch der Bundestag eben arbeitsteilig funktioniert. Aber es ist natürlich, wenn man sagt, Face ID ist kein Problem und so weiter, die meisten Leute wissen natürlich nicht, wie es funktioniert und können deswegen die Fragen gar nicht abschätzen. Und es ist doch okay, wenn mein Hauptjob darin besteht, irgendwie Häuserfassaden mit Stuck zu verputzen, dann warum soll ich denn wissen, wie die funktionieren? Das ist glaube ich so der Punkt.
Okay, dann würde ich jetzt zu dem Punkt kommen, den Anke vorhin angesprochen hat. Nämlich, es gibt ja auch positive Anwendungsgebiete für biometrische Erkennung. Und wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, Anke, meintest du damit irgendwas im medizinischen Bereich.
Ja, ich habe vor ein paar Monaten mal eine sehr interessante Story gelesen über eine Parkinson-Früherkennung anhand der Stimminterpretation. Stimme ist ja auch Biometrie. Und da kam man in irgendein Tool, war noch im wissenschaftlichen Bereich, keine App, die man sich runterladen kann. Aber im Prinzip war es eine Art App. Die ist im Hintergrund mitgelaufen oder man hat ihr da spontan Dinge erzählt, das erinnere ich mich nicht mehr genau. Aber die hat sehr frühzeitig Veränderungen in der Stimme erkennen können. Offenbar hat man da so ein kleines, fängt die Stimme an, ein bisschen zu schleifen. Was man selber gar nicht hört, nicht mal die Bekannten und Verwandten nehmen die Differenz wahr. Aber dieser künstliche Intelligenz-Algorithmus hat die Veränderungen wahrgenommen und kann dann eine Warnung ausgeben, dass hier möglicherweise eine sehr frühe Form von Parkinson vorliegt. Und das fand ich eigentlich ganz interessant. Auch gerade in den letzten Monaten, durch die Medien gegeistert, ist auch so eine Anwendung auch noch auf Forschungsebene, wo man in sein Handy, in diese App hineinhusten konnte. Und dann hat es einem gesagt, ob man wahrscheinlich einen Covid-Husten hat, einen Corona-Husten oder irgendeinen Husten, Raucher-Husten oder keine Ahnung was. Und das war aber wohl noch in der frühen Phase. Da gab es auch Debatte darüber, wie gut die Daten waren. Aber das sind für mich interessante Anwendungsbeispiele, wo das durchaus auch Sinn machen kann. Aber da geht es eben auch nicht um die Identifizierung einer eigentlich anonymen Person, die das möglicherweise gar nicht möchte. Sondern es geht um erstens eine echte Einwilligung und dann um etwas, ich kann das ja auch anonym machen, meine Stimme da testen lassen oder meinen Husten. Da muss ich ja nicht mal die Identität auflegen. Und was ich da mit der Information mache, ist eine ganz andere Geschichte. Also für mich sind das positive Anwendungsbeispiele.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die Gemeinsamkeit ist auch wirklich, das macht man dann halt auch mit Absicht. Und das wird dann nicht irgendwie überläufen. Rainer, du wolltest auch noch?
Ja, das finde ich ein schöner Bogen zu dem, was Andrea auch vorhin gesagt hat. Ich glaube, zum Beispiel die Biometrie jetzt, das ist halt ein visuelles Verfahren, womit wir Körper beobachten. Und deswegen können wir sehen, ob die Leute irgendwie Augenringe haben oder ob sie halt in der Stimme früher Anzeichen von Parkinson. Was wir damit eben nicht können, ist geistige Werte irgendwie auslesen. Oder zumindest ist es sehr, sehr schwierig. Und dann müssen wir ganz genau hinschauen, weil wir sonst in diese dunkle Geschichte wieder zurückkommen. Das heißt, sowas wie ist jemand ein Verbrecher, Verbrecherin? Oder ist jemand aggressiv oder gefährlich oder irgend sowas? Da kann man genau sehen, das ist eben keine, das ist ja erstmal nicht direkt eine körperliche Eigenschaft, sondern es ist eine geistige Eigenschaft. Die kann vielleicht körperliche Anzeichen haben und dann muss man überlegen, ob man die erkennen kann. Aber was jemand im Schilde führt, das waren ja so die dunklen Beispiele, das ist eben eine geistige Eigenschaft. Ob die jetzt körperlich abzulesen, das fällt uns ja als Menschen selbst schwer. Siehe Kommunikationsprobleme und so weiter. Also das glaube ich ist genau dieser Übergang. Man kann feststellen, ob jemand rennt. Aber was das bedeutet, dass die Person rennt, das ist im Bild in der Regel nicht zu erkennen.
Es gibt noch ein schönes Beispiel. Ein Supermarkt hat kürzlich damit beworben, dass man da jetzt sein Gesicht scannen kann und die Anwendung sagt der Person dann, welches Gemüse die Person doch mal essen sollte. Ich habe mir diese Anwendung mal angeschaut und in Wahrheit, also die Anwendung verarbeitet tatsächlich ein Gesicht, soweit war es nicht gelogen. Die Anwendung schätzt dann Geschlecht mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit und das Alter des abgebildeten Gesichts. Und dann wird man auf eine Seite weitergeleitet, wo in Abhängigkeit von der Zeit irgendein Gemüse angezeigt wird. Da spielten die vorgenannten Faktoren gar keine Rolle mehr. Das heißt, zu Werbezwecken werden da völlig falsche Erwartungen auch geweckt.
Da wüsste ich ja echt gerne mal, was so alte Damen im Vergleich zu jungen Männern angeboten kriegen. Die einen Paprika, die anderen Möhrchen oder was?
Das klingt jetzt eher nach, das war völlig irrelevant. Die wollten nur die Daten haben und haben danach ein zufälliges Gemüse gezeigt.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, ja.
Jetzt bin ich verwirrt. Matthias, kannst du noch mal genau sagen, wenn ich dich richtig verstanden habe, haben diese biometrischen Daten keine Rolle gespielt bei der Auswahl des Gemüses. Dann hast du gesagt, in Abhängigkeit von der Zeit.
Das heißt, auch wenn ich das gleiche Gesicht noch mal hochgeladen hab, wurde mir irgendwann später am Tage anderes Gemüse hochgeladen, äh, gezeigt. Und für viele verschiedene Gesichter...
Ach, von dem Gemüse war noch zu viel da. Das wird es gewesen sein.
Ja.
Das Gemüse musste weg.
Und gleichzeitig wurde mir für viele verschiedene Gesichter zum gleichen Zeitpunkt immer das gleiche Gemüse angezeigt.
Das bestätigt meinen Verdacht.
Die Karotten müssen weg.
Ja, keine Lebensmittelverschwendung.
Aber es ist ein schönes Beispiel dafür, wie man eben diese Art von Traumerwartungen weckt, als könne man das machen.
Wäre ich auch anfällig für, sozusagen. Ich tue mich schwer mit gesunder Ernährung. Gerade weil es heutzutage wenig andere Späße gibt, die man treiben kann. Aber wenn mir dann sozusagen so ein quasi-neutrales System sagen würde, Markus ist doch mal eine Möhre.
Also bei Pflanzen funktioniert das ja. Diese Präzisionslandwirtschaft, die hat vorne am Landwirtschaftsgerät traktorartiges Dingsbums, hat die vorne so lichtsensitiven Sensoren, die dann gucken, wie grün ist denn das Salatblatt unter mir. Und dann wird errechnet, wie viel Düngemittel von einem bestimmten Nährstoff genau diese eine Pflanze braucht. Und am hinteren Ende dieser Landmaschine fällt genau diese Menge auf genau diese Pflanze rauf. Und die Pflanze drei Meter weiter, kriegt was anderes oder gar nichts.
Selbst mit als Salattopf, der beregnet wird.
Genau, also da wird halt nur nach Schattierungen von Grün geguckt, was natürlich um ein unendliches einfacher ist, als ein menschliches Gesicht zu interpretieren und zu gucken, bist du blass, bist du nicht blass, hast du Augenringe, brauchst du mehr Spinat.
So, nachdem wir festgestellt haben, dass wir alle mehr Gemüse essen sollten, kommen wir jetzt mal zum politischen Teil. Und auch den würde ich grundsätzlich anfangen. Und zwar, das klang jetzt im Verlauf der Sendung möglicherweise schon an, dass biometrische Überwachung nicht die allergeilste Idee ist. Und zwar nicht nur deswegen, weil es nicht funktioniert. Aber, liebe Anwesende, ich möchte das noch mal ganz von vorne erklärt, das Versprechen, das mit der Überwachung des öffentlichen Raumes einhergeht, ist ja mehr Sicherheit. Wir können auch nachher noch gerne nochmal drüber reden, ob das wirklich funktionieren würde. Aber mal gesetzt, den Fall über eine biometrische Überwachung würde zu mehr Sicherheit führen. Was ist denn dagegen einzuwenden? Warum ist denn eine Überwachung gefährlich? Oder was ist die Kritik daran?
Die ist ausgesprochen vielfältig. Da kann ich als Ex Aussie sprechen. Ich hab DDR und Stasi ja noch persönlich miterlebt und kann bestätigen, wer ständig überwacht wird, fühlt sich nicht frei und ist auch nicht frei. Das ist schlicht so. Und wenn du die ganze Zeit weißt, dass irgendwelche unsichtbaren Kameras dich verfolgen, und heute ist das ja buchstäblich so, dass man theoretisch verfolgt werden kann, also in Großbritannien gibt es kaum noch öffentliche Plätze, wo dich keine Kameras angucken, dann verhältst du dich anders. Dann hast du letztendlich ein eingeschränktes Freiheitsrecht, du hast ein eingeschränktes Demonstrationsrecht, weil du dich nicht mehr anonym äußern kannst in deiner Meinung, was wir eigentliche in der Verfassung so drin stehen haben, weil du rein theoretisch jederzeit identifiziert werden könntest und möglicherweise Menschen von deinen politischen Überzeugungen oder spezifischen Überzeugungen erfahren, von denen du das nicht möchtest. Dann werden Dinge miteinander verbunden, die du nicht verbunden haben möchtest. Du wirst die ganze Zeit behandelt wie ein potenzieller Verbrecher. Also auch wenn jetzt die Personalausweise z.B. sämtliche Fingerabdrücke haben sollen, wir haben doch, glaube ich, alle tief in uns verwurzelt. Fingerabdrücke abnehmen ist was für Verbrecher. Das kennt man aus den Krimis, wo die so ihre Finger abrollen müssen. Das assoziiert man damit. Und wenn jetzt alle das machen müssen, ist das schon eine Behandlung von uns allen, als wären wir potenzielle Verbrecher. Und das gehört sich einfach nicht. Alle Leute, von denen, das hat ja Andrea so schön gesagt, die meisten, fast alle, völlig unschuldig sind und gar keine Verbrecher, die alle zu überwachen und in ihren Grundrechten einzuschränken, ist einfach eine Verletzung des Prinzips der Verhältnismäßigkeit.
Ich möchte an einer Stelle mal nachfragen, weil das nicht allen sofort klar ist, und zwar auf eine Demonstration gehen und anonym sein, wie das zusammengeht. Kannst du das nochmal erklären? Weil ein naiver Blick ist ja so, Moment mal, wenn ich auf einer Demonstration bin, das ist doch öffentlicher Raum, da kann doch jeder sehen, sowieso sehen, dass ich da bin.
Ja, aber ich trag doch nicht einen Personalausweis auf meinem Rücken oder ein Namensschildchen vorn. Also ich bin nicht ohne Weiteres erkennbar. Mit Maske schon mal gleich gar nicht. Aber inzwischen gibt es Gesichtserkennungen, die mit Maske hervorragend funktioniert und eine Erkennungsrate auch von über 80 Prozent hat. Das heißt, ich wäre bei einer normalen Demo für einen Durchschnittspolizisten nicht identifizierbar, für die Kamera schon.
Ich würde das ein bisschen anders beschreiben. Also ich stimme da schon zu, aber ich finde es besser verstehbar, wenn man sich anguckt, was macht denn der Datenschutz eigentlich? Es geht ja nicht darum, dass irgendwie der Bäcker meinen Namen ruft, sondern es geht darum, dass ich Gegenstand von Datenverarbeitung bin. Das heißt, dass ich irgendwo die Straße lang laufe, ist erstmal öffentlich, aber es ist nicht Gegenstand von Datenverarbeitung. Das heißt, ich bin da, aber ich bin sozusagen, die Frage anonymen heißt ja, für wen denn anonymen? Es gibt ja gar keinen Beobachter. Die Leute um mich herum sehen mich, aber die vergessen mich wieder und deren Kopf ist guter, die machen keine Datenverarbeitung. Aber in dem Moment, wo eine Kamera anfängt, etwas aufzunehmen, werden Sachen systematisiert, kategorisiert, sie werden abgespeichert, sie können weitergegeben werden. Auf einmal wird daraus ein Datum. Das heißt, da ändert sich die Qualität. Und wenn diese Kamera zu dem Teil des Staates gehört, die das Altmonopol inne hat, dann wird das noch problematischer. Dass ich auf einer Demo stehe, alleine, ist es völlig egal, ob ich mein Gesicht gerade in die strahlende Sonne halte. Das ist eine freiheitliche demokratische Welt hier. Natürlich kann ich das machen. Das ist ja nicht gleich eine Einwilligung, dass der Staatsapparat mich durchscannen kann. Das ist eben auch ein Teil, ich will mal das, was Anke eben beschrieben hat, von der anderen Seite der Medaille beschreiben, um meiner Meinung nach das Bild auch zu kompletieren. Ich bin nicht die Person, die hinten muss, warum ich nicht abgefilmt werden soll. Sondern ich bin die Person, die sich die Begründung anhören muss, warum ich abgefilmt werden sollte. Denn was du hier gerade sagst, ist, mal angenommen, es brächte uns mehr Sicherheit. Das ist so ein bisschen wie ein Gedankenexperiment. Angenommen, wir würden alle Parkbänke violett abnehmen, das brächte uns mehr Sicherheit. Das können wir gerne diskutieren, aber es ist ja nicht so. Ich möchte von denen, die das mögen, die das machen wollen, möchte ich hören, was genau die Folge davon ist. Und dann kann man die Folgen diskutieren. Und auch die Verhältnismäßigkeit und so weiter. Ich würde mich da ganz in die offensive stellen und sagen, was meinst du denn, was an Sicherheit besser wird? Es gibt ja keine Sicherheit, es gibt nur verschiedene andere Freiheitsrechte. Meine Freiheit, körperliche Unversehrtheit, meine Freiheit auf und so weiter, die werden dann vielleicht von Bösewichten irgendwie eingeschränkt. Aber diese Belege stehen doch hinten und vorne aus. Das ist ja so ein Punkt, den ich da ganz relevant finde. Also ich würde das nicht so defensiv machen.
Okay, eine kleine Ergänzung zu dem, was Rainer sagte. Klassische Videoüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum ist schon doof. Allerdings werden da riesige Datenmengen produziert. Das heißt, damit kann ich gar nicht so einfach dann auch wirklich alle permanent und überall überwachen. Aber wenn ich diese Videodaten biometrisch verarbeite, dann muss ich nur noch diese biometrischen Daten speichern. Und damit werden diese vormals riesigen Datenmengen plötzlich handhabbar. Das macht diese biometrische Überwachungstechnik in meinen Augen noch gefährlicher.
Ja, ich würde gerne noch anbringen, wie die Begründung, mit der der EUGH die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gekippt hatte. Nämlich aus zwei Gründen. Das eine war die Verhältnismäßigkeit. Wegen ganz weniger Verdächtiger werden ganz, ganz viele Unschuldige überwacht und in ihren Freiheitsrechten eingeschränkt. Und genau das Thema, was gerade eben schon beschrieben worden ist, dass die Evidenz nicht nachgewiesen worden ist. Dass man also immer wieder, wie Sascha Lubow das mal schön, esoterische Sicherheitspolitik genannt, auf einem Kongress und ich finde, das passt ganz gut. Und das zitiere ich auch immer wieder gern, weil es genau so ist, die Versprechen, symbolpolitische Sicherheit ohne einen einzigen Nachweis dafür zu erbringen. Und das Problem, wenn wir so eine flächendeckende Gesichtserkennung hätten, ist ja nicht nur, dass ich eine Person an einer Stelle auf dieser einen Demo identifizieren könnte. Ich kann ja auch Bewegungsprofile machen. Ich kann auch feststellen, aha, morgens war sie da, mittags war sie da, abends war sie da. Und ich kann feststellen, mit wem war die Person denn hier, da und da. Ich kann also auch Beziehungsprofile erstellen. Ich kann am Ende wirklich eine vollständige Profilierung einzelner Personen machen. Und dann stellt sich dann auch wieder die Forderung, eigentlich schon sehr, sehr viel früher, die das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch schon aufgestellt hat, nämlich, dass man eine Überwachungsgesamtrechnung braucht, dass man gar nicht nur jede einzelne Maßnahme beurteilen muss nach Nutzen und Verhältnismäßigkeit, also wie viel mehr Sicherheit und wie viele sind betroffen und wie viele nicht, sondern auch, dass man gucken muss, was gibt es denn drum herum noch für andere Maßnahmen und wie addieren die sich übereinander, dass man eben nicht diesen sogenannten Chilling-Effekt kriegt, wo eine Demokratie anfängt, nicht mehr eine Demokratie für freie Menschen zu sein, sondern diktatorische Züge zu kriegen, wo man einfach Menschen massenüberwacht?
Jetzt würde ich sagen, dann doch noch Fragen zu diesem Mehrsicherheit. Jetzt ist ja die Tatsache, Überwachung bringt mehr Sicherheit, kann ja zwei Dinge bedeuten. Das eine ist sozusagen, potenzielle Verbrecher fühlen sich durch die Überwachung abgeschreckt. Und die andere ist, das ist kein direkter Gewinn, weil sich erst mal niemand abgeschreckt wird. Aber wenn Verbrechen passieren, dann kann man die zuverlässiger aufklären, weil man weiß, wer es war. Gibt es zu diesen beiden Annahmen überhaupt schon wissenschaftliche, also außer der Vermutung, dass es so sein könnte, gibt es dazu irgendwelche Arbeiten oder Ergebnisse? Weiß man da was?
Also man weiß zumindest, dass der Staatstrojaner nicht erfolgreich eingesetzt worden ist in den letzten, weiß nicht, ein Jahr, zwei Jahre.
Den Staatstrojaner würde ich jetzt sozusagen nicht unter anlasslose Massenüberwachung...
Es ist eine Überwachungsmaßnahme, die den gleichen Charakter hat wie alle anderen, dass sie nie evaluiert und nie überprüft wird. Selbst wenn es in einem Gesetz drin steht, das wird dann einfach nicht gemacht.
Genau, also bei Videoüberwachung ist es ja glaube ich auch schon lange bekannt, dass das überhaupt keinerlei Straftaten verhindert. Dann käme es eher in die zweite Frage rein, was ist, wenn jetzt jemand gefunden wird, durch eine Videoüberwachung später, wo der Mord schon begangen ist, die Person schon verprügelt ist oder was auch immer. Ja, also würde ich auch nicht sagen, dass das dann wirklich, also das ist auch nicht wirklich hilfreich. Also bisher sind Verbrechen nicht minimiert worden durch diese Überwachungstechniken.
Und Aufklärungsquoten auch nicht in die Höhe gegangen.
Genau, auch nicht in die Höhe gegangen. Das ist immer nur das Versprechen. Und das zieht tatsächlich auch so einen Druck nach, sich eine Aufklärung zu erbringen. Also es gibt so eine schöne Geschichte aus 2017, wo in New York ein Ladendiebstahl mit Biometrie aufgeklärt wurde. Völlig absurd. Das AFIS, das automatisierte Fingerabdruckidentifikationssystem der New Yorker, das NYPD, hat niemand gefunden auf das Foto hin vom Tatort sozusagen. Das war so verpixelt. Und die Person, die da einen Diebstahl begangen hat, die war nicht zu erkennen. Dann hat die Polizei kreativ, wie sie war, gedacht. Also ein Polizist meinte, der sieht irgendwie Woody Harrelson ähnlich in so und so Filmen, Natural Born Killers oder wo auch immer. Dann haben die sich ein gut aufgelöstes Foto von Woody Harrelson, ein passendes, mit dem man gut eine Datenbank durchsuchen kann, bei Google gesucht und haben mit dem Foto von Woody Harrelson eine Kandidatenliste aus dem ARFIS rausgeholt und haben daraufhin tatsächlich jemanden festgenommen.
Aber funktioniert doch anscheinend.
Super.
Ein blindes Wumm findet auch mal einen Korn. Genau, aber das Interessante ist, da gibt es diesen schönen Podcast von MIT Technology Review, diesen in Machines We Trust. Da wird auch ein Polizist dazu interviewt und der kann überhaupt nichts Falsches daran erkennen. Also es ist halt so eine Zwangsläufigkeit. Wir haben doch jetzt die ganze Technik, wir müssen doch jetzt irgendwie hinfinden.
Oder wolltest du noch was sagen?
Nee, das nimmt dann auch so absurde Züge oft an. Und wo Anke DDR oder Sozialismus angesprochen hat, sind ja auch so Systeme gewesen, in denen es angeblich wegen des Sozialismus keine Kriminalität mehr geben durfte. Das durfte. Die gab es natürlich trotzdem. Häusliche Gewalt, wirklich Schwerverbrechen, das gab es natürlich alles. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ein Irrglaube, mit irgendeiner, also menschliche Gesellschaft, mit irgendeiner Form von Repression und Überwachung da hinzubringen, dass sie sicherer wird im Sinne von niemand tut mir jemand anderes irgendwas Böses an.
Aber wie ist das? Ich wollte nochmal da auch anschließen gerne, wenn das passt. Und zwar, ich finde diese Unterscheidung zwischen verhindern und im Nachhinein aufklären, ich finde die super wichtig, weil wenn da irgendwas verhindern, dann gleich über wesentliche Sachen gucken, nachdenken und sprechen. Aber die einzigen Sachen, die tatsächlich irgendwie Verbrechen verhindern, sind diese vorherige, was weiß ich, was auch immer man da als soziale Prävention von der Sozialarbeit, Überbildung und so weiter, kann man ja ewig groß, aber es ist eigentlich komplizierter, aber tatsächlich helfen. Das Quoten, das hat man auch in Berlin gesehen zu der Zeit, wo die BVG angefangen hat mit Videoüberwachung, die haben sich einfach auch nicht verändert. Das heißt, wenn da mal einer gefunden wird, den dann insbesondere die Konservativen gerne hochhalten und sagen, wenn auch nur ein Menschenleben gerettet würde, dann nützt es schon. Das sind die gleichen Leute, die dann gegen eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit aufauten. Aber gut, wenn nur eine Person gerettet würde, dann hat sich das schon gelohnt. So kann man natürlich nicht Politik machen und auch nicht irgendwie eine Gesellschaft strukturieren. Diese drei Fälle gibt es sicherlich, aber das ist überhaupt nicht relevant an der Stelle. Natürlich glaube ich, wir sind ja alle für mehr Sicherheit. Also im Sinne von uns passiert nichts, wenn wir da rumlaufen. Aber mich stört daran an der Diskussion, ich weiß nicht, warum die Verfechter das tatsächlich verfechten, weil sozusagen alle Evidenz weist in ganz andere Richtungen. Also was weiß ich, soziale Brennpunkte usw. Und wenn wir uns auch angucken, die Krimisraten zumindest in den Städten hier, sind überall sinkend. Also ich sehe auch nicht das Flammenmeer, was über die Welt hereinbricht, wenn wir nicht auf einmal alle öffentlichen Plätze überwachen. Ich sehe auch das Bedrohungsszenario an der Stelle gar nicht. Und an der anderen Seite sagen dann die Polizeikräfte selber, wir sind total understaffed, wir wissen nicht, was Tor ist. Deswegen rauschen wir bei Leuten rein, die so einen Server bei sich in der Wohnung stehen haben. Teilweise haben wir nicht genug Benzin für die Autos usw. Da denke ich mir so ein bisschen, wenn wir wahrhaftig über Sicherheit diskutieren, dann ist biometrische Videoüberwachung von öffentlichen Plätzen der letzte Punkt, den wir überhaupt durchdenken sollten. Ich verstehe diese ganze Diskussion dabei nicht. Und das ist natürlich, ja, vielleicht könnt ihr mir helfen.
Vielleicht kann Anke dazu noch was erzählen, weil sie hatte ja vorhin schon so eine kleine Anekdote aus der KI-Anket. Und wenn ihr euch mit dem Thema beschäftigt habt, werden da ja unter Umständen vermutlich auch BefürworterInnen gesessen haben. Was sind denn, also hast du da ein Gefühl für, oder vielleicht auch aus einer anderen Arbeit, aus den anderen Teilen deiner Arbeit im Bundestag, was die Idee dahinter ist? Also das müsste man, also selbst wenn man den Befürwortern das Bestmögliche unterstellt, müssen die ja mindestens zugeben, dass es so eine Art Rechtsgüterabwägung gibt. Und dann fällt mir aber sozusagen genau nur das Beispiel an, was Rainer gesagt hat, nämlich man sagt halt, ja nur ein Menschenleben, das muss dann halt irgendwie rechtfertigen, dass wir alle überwacht werden. Aber warum? Kannst du dazu was sagen?
Also ich glaube, bei den Innenpolitikern konservativer Parteien gibt es einerseits eine Überbetonung von Aspekten innerer Sicherheit, die mit mit Strafverfolgung zu tun haben, mehr als mit Prävention. Das ist ja eigentlich genau das Thema, was wir gerade auch hatten. Und weil es dieses Übergewicht der Strafverfolgung geht, also Leute bestrafen, wichtiger ist, als Opfer zu verhindern, deswegen setzt man auch jetzt zusätzlich besonders auf Technik, weil es sich, glaube ich, die sich das oft auch einreden. Ich glaube, manchmal glauben die das tatsächlich, dass man damit was bewirken kann. Und die haben vielleicht in dem von mir zitierten Beispiel nicht geglaubt, dass man überall nur eine 0, 1% Fehlerrate hat. Aber die haben sich gedacht, 80% sind ja auch gut. Dann sind halt 20% Fehler drauf geschissen. Hauptsache 80%. Aber was ich gerne noch erzählen würde, wir hatten ja auch diverse Anträge in dieser Legislatur, mal am Bundestag, wo es darum ging, dass es keinen Einsatz biometrischer Gesichtserkennung in öffentlichen Räumen geben soll. Das ist jetzt im Januar im Bundestag im Plenum debattiert worden. Da haben Grüne, Linke und FDP sich also ganz explizit gegen diese Gesichtserkennung ausgesprochen. SPD und Union waren da deutlich moderater. Also die SPD sagt dann, sie will auf jeden Fall mehr Debatte zum Thema haben. Die Union, die in den Kreisen, wo ich in der Enquete-Kommission drin war, immer alles ganz toll fand und schön viel Überwachung haben wollte, die haben zumindest da im Plenum erklärt, die wollen Rechtsfragen prüfen. Aber eine Partei, Überraschung, die AfD, die hat es halt ein wunderbares Verhandlungsinstrument gefunden. Und das bringt mich gleich zu einer potentiellen anderen Nebenwirkung, nämlich der Frage, was passiert denn mit einer flächendeckenden Überwachungsinfrastruktur, wenn bestimmte Personen oder politische Ausrichtungen, die unter ihrer Kontrolle kriegen. Und da ist mir relativ klar, warum die AfD solche feuchten Träume hatte, weil die einfach davon träumen, bestimmte Leute ausfindig zu machen und im Zweifelsfall schlimme Dinge mit denen zu tun, alle ins Gefängnis zu stecken, aufzuhängen oder was weiß ich. Da wird ja nicht viel Hehl draus gemacht. Und da wundert mich das nicht, weil die sind ja auch keine großen Verteidiger von Grundrechten. Die Grundrechte sind denen im Prinzip scheißegal. Also jetzt im Zusammenhang mit Corona-Demos finden sie bestimmte Grundrechte total wichtig, aber normalerweise nicht. Insofern ist es aus deren Sicht völlig nachvollziehbar. Tolles Fahndungsinstrument, was interessieren uns die Grundrechte. SPD und Union wägen zumindest ab. Grüne Linke und FDP sind allerdings ganz klar dagegen.
Und beim ganz klar dagegen sein kommen wir jetzt zum Anlass dieser Sendung, nämlich dieser Kampagne. Reclaim Your Face ist eine europäische Kampagne. Und auch hier eine einfache Frage, was genau wollen die eigentlich? Also letztlich sozusagen ihr, weil ihr alle sozusagen irgendwie mit drin hängt. Teilweise konkret auf der Webseite als Testimonial. Teilweise weil ihr sozusagen unterstützenden Organisationen angehört.
Genau, wir...
Was ist das Ziel?
Wir fordern ein Verbot biometrischer Massenüberwachung. Und zwar von der Europäischen Union. Konkret von der Europäischen Kommission. Weil das die sind, die auf EU-Ebene Gesetzentwürfe vorlegen können.
Das heißt sozusagen, die würden den Gesetzentwurf vorlesen, der würde dann beschlossen. Und wenn das so ist, würde der ein nationales Recht umgesetzt, dann hätte man das Problem EU-weit erschlagen. Gibt es, also hat diese Kampagne einen konkreten Gesetzesvorschlag? Wird der da mitgeliefert? Oder ist eher so die Sache so, Leute, ihr müsst euch da jetzt mal darum kümmern?
Letzteres, also es gibt keinen konkreten Vorschlag, sondern die Aufforderung ist relativ kurz gehalten. Wir fordern ein Verbot biometrischer Massenüberwachung, und dann wird das noch kurz begründet.
Jetzt wird im Rahmen dieser Kampagne werden 1 Mio. Unterschriften gesammelt. Sind das 1 Mio. Unterschriften, weil das eine schöne Zahl ist? Oder hängt da irgendeine technische Konsequenz dran?
Da hängt tatsächlich was dran, weil das nicht einfach nur so eine Online-Kampagne ist, wo man mal Unterschriften sammelt, sondern das ist eine europäische Bürgerinitiative. Das heißt, wenn wir diese 1 Mio. Unterschriften plus einen gewissen Puffer sammeln, dann muss die EU-Kommission sich mit unserem Thema befassen. Es gibt dann erst ein Treffen mit der EU-Kommission, dann gibt es eine öffentliche Anhörung im Europäischen Parlament. Danach muss ich wieder die Kommission öffentlich und schriftlich zu unserem Vorhaben äußern und auch erklären. da hängt rechtlich was dran. Das ist eine ordentliche Bürgerinneninitiative.
D.h. ist das vergleichbar mit den E-Petitionen vom Bundestag? Wenn man genug Unterschriften zusammen hat, dann muss sich der gesetzgebende Körper damit beschäftigen?
Genau, das ist was Vergleichbares auf EU-Ebene.
Und diese eine Million, die da gefordert wird, ist das viel? Oder ist das eher das... Ich hab von dem Instrument vorher noch nie gehört, aber das wird ja nicht für jetzt erfunden worden sein. Gibt es da Erfahrungen? Sind eine Millionen viel? Oder ist das eigentlich so ein Ding, wenn man nur genug Leute zusammenbringt, die kräftig trommeln, dann geht das schon?
Eine Million ist sehr viel, sag ich. Es geht nicht nur um eine Million, sondern in verschiedenen Ländern muss man auch noch bestimmte Quoten erreichen. In Deutschland zum Beispiel müssen etwa 70.000 Unterschriften zusammenkommen. Und das alleine sind schon mal mehr als für die E-Petition beim Bundestag notwendig.
Das heißt 7 Millionen?
Das muss auch eine Mindestanzahl Länder erreicht sein. Da weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht. Mindestens 7. Ich hab jetzt gedacht, irgendwas zwischen 5 und 10. 7 passt ja dann ganz genau. Es können auch nicht ein Land da groß mobilisieren und dann der ganzen EU so eine Debatte aufzwingen. Ungarn oder Polen könnte einem da als schlechtes Beispiel einfallen. Wobei, auch da gibt es eine Zivilgesellschaft, die sich wehrt gegen bestimmte Dinge. Es ist schon ein paar Mal erreicht worden, glaube ich. Mindestens einmal erinnere ich mich, als es um das Recht auf Zugang zu Wasser ging. Die haben relativ schnell, glaube ich, sogar die 1 Million geknackt. Aber es ist wirklich nicht einfach. Das ist schon eine hohe Hürde.
Wir sprechen heute hier nur mit deutschen VertreterInnen. Jetzt ist es eine EU-weite Kampagne. Wie findet die Zusammenarbeit statt?
Zu Beginn haben sich vor allem Organisationen zusammengetan, die gemeinsam über European Digital Rights organisiert sind. EDRI, das ist, man kann fast sagen, so eine Art Dachverband Europäischer Datenschutz- und Netzpolitik-Organisation. Und aus EDRI heraus wurde, ja, Reclame Your Face, dieses Bündnis aufgestellt. Und inzwischen sind wir über das EDRI-Netzwerk hinaus deutlich gewachsen.
Und heißt das aber so sagen, ihr macht für Deutschland die Arbeit und das ist in anderen Ländern auch so? Oder gibt es tatsächlich, und EDRI organisiert das einfach alles und managet das? Oder ist es tatsächlich so, dass da auch ein inter-europäischer Austausch in einem, keine Ahnung, wöchentlichen Big Blue Button Call stattfindet?
Ja, tatsächlich genauso, wobei wir uns alle zwei Wochen über Big Blue Button treffen. Zumindest mit den Organisationen, die im Kern dabei sind, die aktiver dabei sind. Und darüber hinaus gibt es eine Mailing-Liste, über die wir uns austauschen.
Und kannst du sagen oder könnt ihr sagen, wie viele Länder da jetzt mit am Start sind? Sind das alle oder gerade mal die sieben, die man braucht? Und wie ist die Begeisterung in anderen Ländern?
Und der Schwerpunkt liegt auf den sieben geforderten Ländern. Aber ich glaube, es sind inzwischen mehr als sieben.
Ich habe inzwischen schon acht gezählt. Ich hatte mal geguckt, wer so dabei ist. Also da ist aus Italien die Human Rights Group Hermes Center dabei, aus Griechenland Homo Digitalis, Bits of Freedom aus den Niederlanden, Juridikum Remedium aus Tschechien, Schere Foundation aus Serbien. Aus Deutschland gibt es weit über zehn verschiedene. Dann gibt es die Panoptikon Foundation aus Polen, La Quadratür du Net aus Frankreich. Das waren jetzt schon acht. Und ist möglicherweise ja nicht mal eine vollständige Liste.
Und die Unterschrift gibt man wie ab?
Derzeit noch online, entweder bei verschiedenen Partnerorganisationen oder zentral auf der Webseite reclaimyourface.eu. Ja, reclaimyourface.eu. Das heißt, da ist ja ein Feld, wo man ausnahmsweise, eben weil es eine europäische Bürgerinitiative ist, nicht nur Name und Mailadresse hinterlassen muss, sondern auch seine Postadresse in Deutschland ein. Und damit kann man dann online unterschreiben. Wir arbeiten aber auch daran, dass man über Papier was ausdrucken kann, das unterschreibt, und dann sammeln wir das irgendwie ein. Die Planung ist aber noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen.
Diese Kampagne oder diese Titel gibt es ja irgendwie seit Ende letzten Jahres. Aber jetzt ist Mitte Februar erst offiziell losgegangen, dieses mit den Unterschriften sammeln. In einem Jahr hat man da Zeit. Ich hab heute nachher noch einmal drauf geguckt, da waren es irgendwie so knapp 27.000, glaube ich. Das ist natürlich bis zu einem Million noch ein ganz schöner Schritt. Seid ihr zufrieden mit dem, wie es jetzt gerade geht? Also die Geschwindigkeit, mit der da Dinge schon angelaufen sind?
Ja und nein. Momentan sind wir über dem Schnitt, den wir pro Tag halten müssen. Also pro Schnitt mit ein bisschen Puffer landen wir bei knapp 3000 Unterschriften, die wir pro Tag sammeln müssen. Wir sind jetzt bei Tag 8. Allerdings gab es am Anfang so ein paar auch technische WW-Chien, die jetzt nach und nach aufgelöst werden und wurden.
Ich hab übrigens im Rahmen dieses Thema mit einer Forschung gesprochen von der FU Berlin. Die hatten mir was ganz Spannendes erzählt. Die haben geforscht zur Gesichtserkennung, zur Akzeptanz von Gesichtserkennung in verschiedenen Ländern. Die hat gesagt, in Deutschland ist es Genia Kostas heißt die üben. Kostka heißt die übrigens. Die hat erzählt, dass es in Deutschland ganz krass ist, weil im privaten Bereich wird Gesichtserkennung eher abgelehnt und im öffentlichen Bereich eher angenommen. Und das, obwohl die Menschen eigentlich wissen, dass Überwachung nicht so ganz gut ist. Sie vermutet so ein bisschen, dass da auch so eine Resignation stattfindet. Das ist ja eh Teil unseres Lebens, da können wir sowieso nichts machen. Das stelle ich mir aber für so eine Kampagne als ein ganz schwieriges Zielpublikum vor. Die also eh sagen, na ja, warum eigentlich nicht? Und dann außerdem eh so ein bisschen resigniert haben. Es gibt diese Website, es gibt ja auch, ihr macht Medienarbeit, diese Sendung findet gerade statt. Aber habt ihr da einen Plan, oder ist das einfach reinpowern und hoffen, dass man bei den Leuten ankommt? Oder vielleicht reichen ja die, die von der guten Sache TM überzeugt sind?
Also ich glaube, das reicht nicht. Momentan beschränken sich die unterstützenden Organisationen fast noch auf die übliche, ich sag mal Datenschutzbubble. Aber wir arbeiten gerade daran, genau diese Datenschutzbubble zu verlassen und eben auch Organisationen einzubinden, die das Thema auch betrifft. Zum Beispiel Organisation Die Geflüchtete unterstützen. Weil eben auch an Grenzen biometrische Überwachung stattfindet.
Ich habe noch einen weiteren Kommentar. Also müssen wir genau gucken, woher dieser Eindruck Leute da irgendwie, vielleicht sind sie tatsächlich, wie du gesagt hast, ich weiß nicht, entmutigt. Man kann aber auch genau so sagen, jetzt passiert da mal was. Und man muss glaube ich auch, ich finde es total wichtig, es ist ja nicht so, dass hier irgendwie ein paar Leute sich zusammengefrimmelt haben und die einfach eine Meinung haben. Auch der europäische Datenschutzbeauftragte selbst hat verlautbaren lassen, es war im Oktober 2019, facial recognition, a solution in search of a problem. Also er hat sich auch ausgesprochen, als sozusagen EU-Institution, da mal ein Memorandum zu machen. Also es war jetzt so halberfolgreich. Aber ich will auch damit nur sagen, das hat schon auch sozusagen, auch auf dieser ist es jetzt nicht einfach nur irgendwie, ich antwurche, eine NGO-Forderung, sondern es ist auch sehr gut begründet, warum das eine gute Idee ist. Das sind jetzt auch nicht so wie spinnarte Leute oder so. Wie man natürlich mehr Leute dafür noch kriegen kann, das wird man sehen. Aber ich würde sagen, das hat auf alle Fälle was damit zu tun, das gut zu begründen und auch einfach eine Option aufzumachen. Man kann halt eh nichts tun, die Leute geben auf oder so, sondern zu sagen, natürlich, wir sind halt eine Demokratie und ihr hängt davon ab, dass Leute sich äußern. Das ist das, was jetzt gerade überall ausgerollt wird im schlechtesten Falle. Natürlich kann man das aufhalten.
Ich glaube, es gibt jetzt sogar so ein Möglichkeitenfenster, gerade in Bezug auf die Europäische Union. Die Europäische Kommission schreibt ja gerade an so einem White Paper zu künstlicher Intelligenz. Und da war bereits von Seiten der Europäischen Kommission gesagt worden, dass sie sehr hart darüber nachdenken, ein Moratorium für Gesichtserkennung an öffentlichen Orten zu verhängen innerhalb Europas. Was ja bedeutet, dass bestimmte Länder, die das schon ganz viel haben und das wieder rückgängig machen müssten, weil sie auch sehen, dass es da irgendwelche Probleme gibt. Das ist in der aktuellen Version nicht mehr drin. Aber immerhin waren sie ja so weit, schon mal laut drüber nachzudenken. Und es gibt gerade diverse Städte in den USA, wie San Francisco oder Boston oder Cambridge, wo die zumindest auf der Stadtebene entschieden haben, dass sie Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum nicht mehr einsetzen, aus bestimmten Gründen solche Überwachungstechnologien ablehnen. Und selbst große Firmen wie IBM, Microsoft oder Amazon haben angekündigt, Gesichtserkennungstechnik nicht mehr an Polizei zu verkaufen. Oder so lange nicht anzubieten, Microsoft hat das so formuliert, wie es keine Gesetzesgrundlage gibt, die garantiert, dass Menschenrechte eingehalten werden. Das heißt, selbst die Firmen kommen, IBM hat sogar den Verkauf komplett eingestellt und hat gesagt, sie wollen diese Technik, dass sie nicht für Massenüberwachung genutzt wird. Und da gibt es, glaube ich, eine Möglichkeit. Und wenn man jetzt in Deutschland noch bedenkt, dass wir vor einer Bundestagswahl stehen, wo die Sensibilität für Massenaktionen, für den Wunsch herauszufinden, wie tickt denn das Wahlvolk relativ hoch ist, da würde ich mal sagen, ist das kein schlechter Zeitpunkt.
Ich fand ganz kurz, in diesem Zusammenhang fand ich Matthias Aktion auch super spannend, sich wegen Clearview AI ein bisschen zu kümmern. Also das würde ich mir jetzt auch nochmal wünschen, dass wir kurz darüber reden, weil ich glaube auch, soweit ich das verstanden habe, ist ja die Poerte auch so ein bisschen, dass der Datenschutzbeauftragte, der dir da geholfen hat, Matthias...
Stopp, stopp, stopp, jetzt musst du die Geschichte von vorne erzählen.
Ja genau, jetzt soll Matthias sie erzählen, weil sie ist wirklich sehr schön.
Ja, dann erzähle ich jetzt die Geschichte von Clearview AI. Das ist eine Gesichtersuchmaschine mit Sitz in New York City. Und die haben mal eben drei Milliarden Bilder im Internet analysiert und die Gesichter da biometrisch verarbeitet. Das Ganze hat die New York Times vor 13 Monaten ungefähr veröffentlicht. Und weil es Bilder von mir im Internet gibt, habe ich diese Gesichtersuchmaschine mal nach meinen personenbezogenen Daten gefragt. Und ja, einen Monat später hat die Suchmaschine tatsächlich geantwortet und hat mir gezeigt, wo sie mein Gesicht schon im Internet gefunden hat. Das fand ich dann nicht in Ordnung, weil die Firma offensichtlich meine biometrischen Daten ohne meine Zustimmung verarbeitet hat. Und daraufhin habe ich mich beim Hamburgischen Datenschutzbeauftragten beschwert. Dann gab es ein wenig Hin und Her, ob jetzt die Datenschutzgrundverordnung anwendbar sei oder nicht. Wir kamen zu dem Schluss, dass die Datenschutzgrundverordnung angewendet werden kann, weil diese Suchmaschine unter anderem das Verhalten europäischer Bürgerinnen und Bürger beobachtet, dadurch, dass sie ebenso umfassend Bilder im Internet sucht und verarbeitet. Und vor wenigen Wochen, knapp einem Monat, hat der Hamburgische Datenschutzbeauftragte dann entschieden, dass das, was Clearview AI dort macht, nicht in Ordnung ist. Allerdings wurde nur angeordnet, dass diese Suchmaschine das zu meiner Person gehörende biometrische Datum löschen muss. Das heißt, die Suchmaschine hat noch mein Bild und die biometrischen Daten aller anderen Europäerinnen und Europäer stecken auch noch in dieser Suchmaschine. Insofern denke ich, dass wir da etwas tun müssen. Es wurde festgestellt, das, was die Suchmaschine tut, das ist nicht so ganz legal. Aber wir helfen jetzt nur mal dieser einen Person, die sich beschwert hat, und bei den anderen tun wir nichts. Das kann es aus meiner Sicht noch nicht sein.
Das Interessante an der Sache ist ja, dass du im Prinzip erst diesen hamburgischen Datenschutz, Kaspar, wie heißt er? Du hast den erst draufgebracht, die DSGVO auch mal sinnvoll anzuwenden. Das ist jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen überspitzt formuliert, aber die Waffen sind ja da. Die DSGVO bietet ziemlich viel Handlungsspielraum. Sie wird aber nicht so richtig verwendet, um gegen Gesichtserkennung ins Feld zu ziehen. Das ist insgesamt so ein Problem mit der DSGVO. Da wird noch nicht so richtig rundeum mitgeschlagen. Da geht einiges. Das finde ich eine ziemlich schöne Poernte bei der Geschichte. Übrigens interessiert mich in dem Zusammenhang, hast du denn von Clearview AI die ganze Kandidatenliste bekommen? Also alle, die auf deinem Foto gematcht haben oder nur deins dann auch?
Das war sehr interessant. Ich habe einmal nach meinen Daten gefragt und dann haben sie mir wirklich nur meine Gesichter geliefert, zwei Stück. Ein Vierteljahr später, zwischendurch haben sie gesagt, meine Daten wurden jetzt gelöscht, mein Suchbild. Und ein Vierteljahr später haben sie dann trotzdem ungefragt noch einmal Auskunft erteilt. Und dieses Mal war ich zweimal zu sehen und dann waren dann noch acht andere Personen auf meinem Suchauszug.
Das waren also neue Bilder?
Genau.
Du hast dann aber konsequenterweise alle löschen lassen, oder?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich habe jetzt nochmal nach meinen Daten gefragt.
Warte mal, das waren Bilder, da warst du drauf, aber auch andere Menschen? Oder du hast sozusagen Bilder bekommen, wo du nicht drauf warst, aber Leute, für die das System dich gehalten hat?
Sowohl als auch. Also die zwei Bilder, die gefunden wurden, die zeigen wirklich mich.
Warst du mal in einem Supermarkt? Mir fällt bei der Gelegenheit aber auch noch eine ganz lustige Geschichte ein, und zwar ist es eine Recherche, die Netzpolitik gemacht hat. Die haben nämlich eine Firma ausgegraben, die so etwas Ähnliches macht, aber einen Sitz im Polen hat, also mitten in der Europäischen Union. Die heißen PIM-Eis, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Die haben sich gedacht, wollen wir doch mal ein paar Abgeordnete anspitzen, und wie funktioniert es am besten, indem die betroffen sind. Also haben sie gedacht, nehmen wir doch mal zum Beispiel Anke, ich war nicht die einzige, aber haben da so mal irgendein öffentliches Foto von mir da hochgeladen. Und da spuckt einem dann diese Software oder dieser Dienst, spuckt einem dann alle möglichen Bilder aus, die ich sein soll, von egal wo im Internet. Und da gibt es ja auch ein paar. Und es hat 50, 60 Fotos gefunden. Ich kannte einige davon überraschenderweise überhaupt nicht. Und es waren wirklich, sagen wir mal, so 90% war ich. Vielleicht sogar noch ein paar Prozent mehr. Es waren ganz wenige, die dann aber auch völlig anders aussahen, wo ich mich noch gefragt hab, hä? Aber das meiste war ich. Und in manchen Sachen, ich weiß noch eins war, da saß ich als Publikum bei irgendeiner Talkshow im superdunklen, kaum zu erkennen, ganz winzig, nur eine ganz kleine, halbdunkle Gesichtsformation. Und das hat mich trotzdem da erkannt. Das war sehr weird. Es waren teilweise 10, 15 Jahre alte Fotos. Und da ich mich natürlich auch tierisch aufgeregt hab, ihr habt sie wohl nicht alle, darf nicht sein, und hab mich bei der brandenburgischen Datenschutzbeauftragten, weil die Länderebene von da, wo ich wohne, es zuständig beschwert, hab aber gedacht, schade auch nichts, wenn man dem Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten Ulrich Kelber darüber in Kenntnis setzt, habt auch einen schönen Brief hingeschrieben. Beide haben auch geantwortet. Also beide waren der Meinung, es ist ein Fall für die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, und zwar schon mal deshalb, weil das Unternehmen sich in Europa befindet und weil ich als Europäerin betroffen bin. Aber weil es ein europäisches Unternehmen ist, ist der polnische Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte, also von ganz Polen dafür zuständig. Und an den wurde das Verfahren von der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragten in Brandenburg übergeben. Der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hat aber auch einen Brief hingeschrieben und hat gesagt, dass er dieses Verfahren quasi überwacht aus der Ferne und sich da Bericht erstatten lässt von den Polen. Und nachdem die Polen dieses polnische Unternehmen früher auf der Webseite noch angepriesen haben, dass man da zum Beispiel Fotos von der Ex oder Privatfotos von Celebrities finden kann, die die vielleicht gar nicht öffentlich haben wollen, das haben sie alles dann ganz schnell weggelöscht. Und sie haben dann in den nächsten Wochen auch ihren Firmen-Sitz vom Polen weg verlegt auf irgendeiner einsamen, weit weg Briefkastenfirmen-Insel. Und wie das jetzt weitergeht, weiß ich nicht. Aber es ist meines Wissens noch ein anhängiges Verfahren. Also das ist noch nicht vorbei. Und mit ein bisschen Glück müssen die wenigstens ordentlich zahlen.
Ich habe mich da auch beschwert. Für das Verfahren könnte es ganz interessant sein, ob die Firma noch ihre Büros und ihre Niederlassung in Wrocław, in Polen nutzt. Also wenn da jemand zuhört, der da zufällig vorbeikommt, ich würde mich über ein Foto fragen.
Das Schöne ist ja, dass die DSGVO auf alle zutrifft, die in Europa die Services anbieten. Egal wo sie sitzen, wie man dann da hinkommt. Das ist natürlich eine andere Frage. Aber ich finde das ist ein total gutes Beispiel, wo ich mich auch manchmal frage, warum müssen die Datenschutzbehörden da eigentlich zum Jagen getragen werden? Also offensichtlich sind sie auch einfach nicht ausgestattet.
Aber meine haben das beide gerne gemacht. Die können sowas nicht so ohne weiteres agieren und haben sich gefreut von mir, diesen Brief zu kriegen. Also alle beide, Bundesebene und Brandenburger Ebene, sind sofort losmarschiert.
Genau, doch, aber gerade die PIM-Eis, das ging doch durch die Medien rauf und runter. Wenn das mein Job ist, warum, also weiß ich nicht. Oder auch Johannes Kaspar, den Andrea von meinte in Hamburg, ich weiß auch nicht, warum da nicht aktiv... Also gerade an solchen symbolischen Punkten, das ist ja auch Vertrauensaufbau gegenüber den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern. Wenn die Datenschutzbehörden nicht nur rumhängen und sagen, Facebook ist ja ganz schön schlimm, sondern mal sagen...
Also jetzt, das ist nicht so, dass sie... Also man kann über die politische Arbeit des Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, der Länderdatenschutzbeauftragten sicherlich reden, aber dass die den ganzen Tag einfach nur rumhängen, das halte ich doch für eine etwas arge Überspitzung.
Das stimmt natürlich. Ja, ja, da hast du schon völlig recht. Aber wir reden gerade davon, dass wir in Europa eine Welle von KI, von US-amerikanischen monopolistischen Riesenfirmen haben, mit biometrischer Videoüberwachung, hinten autonomes Fahren, vorne rum irgendwie. Also ich sehe schon, dass da was passiert. Aber wenn wir das Konzept einer Digitalisierung ernst nehmen, dann müssen wir doch vielleicht zumindest die Datenschutzbeauftragten in gleichem Maße wachsen lassen, wie wir die Geheimdienste wachsen lassen. Genau diese Bissigkeit. Ich wollte das jetzt gar nicht vorwerfen im Sinne von, sondern die sind ja auch hinten und vorne überlastet. Aber das meine ich halt damit. Wir reden alle seit 30 Jahren von der Informationsgesellschaft. Aber dann brauchen wir doch eben auch so eine bissigen Leute und dürfen nicht ständig auf Max Schrems warten. Also so meine ich das.
Es gibt jetzt diese Kampagne, zu der ich gerne zurückkehren möchte. Zu der hätte ich noch zwei Fragen. Die eine ist tatsächlich noch mal zu den Protagonisten. Es gibt ja diese Länder, es gibt EU-weit, jedes Land macht das dann dort. In Deutschland ist die Seite dann gesichtserkennung-stoppen.de und da gibt es dann sehr bekannte Testimonials. Ein gewisser Rainer Rehak ist auf der Seite zum Beispiel zu sehen. Oder eben auch der gerade benannte Ulrich Kälber, Konstanze Kurz, Markus Bekedahl, eine gewisse Anke Domscheit-Berg. Wenn man sich die Liste anguckt, sind das schon typische Player der deutschen Netzpolitik slash AktivistInnen-Bubble. Aber die Initiatoren der Deutschen Netz-Live ist ein Verein, der heißt Digitale Freiheit. Der war mir bis neulich noch überhaupt nicht über den Weg gelaufen. Und über den weiß ich auch, oder kann man auch nicht schnell viel rausfinden. Und das Vertrauen, dass das sozusagen vertrauenswerte Leute sind, kommt unter anderem daher, dass sie halt dieses Projekt anscheinend initiiert haben und dort sehr viele Leute mitmachen, die wiederum dann einen guten Leum und haben. Wer ist denn das eigentlich?
Also das ist ne Aktivistinnengruppe, die ist so plus minus an der TU Berlin angesiedelt. Und die sind so ein bunter Haufen, jetzt nicht riesengroß. Aber die hatten an dem Punkt, also ich kenn die auch so ein bisschen, schon ein bisschen länger, die fanden einfach Zeit, da gibt's ein Problem. Und offensichtlich gibt's da sozusagen niemanden, der da so ein bisschen die Fäden zusammenführt. Und die haben dann ihr Netz jeweils genutzt, um mit den entsprechenden Leuten zu sprechen. Und mit je mehr coolen Leuten man spricht, umso mehr andere coole Leute, sag ich jetzt mal, haben dann auch Lust, was dazu zu sagen. Und die gibt's auch schon, also ich hab die auch kennengelernt, 2017, da waren sie bei der Festtafel der Freiheit irgendwie auch dabei und haben da so einen Wagen gemacht mit Musik für Datenschutz und so. Also die sind so eine bunte Runde von Leuten, die finden, dass da mal was passieren muss. Und ab und zu machen sie halt so eine Art von, das war dann einfach so ein Projekt, was sie so angegangen sind.
Und die letzte Frage, die ich noch hätte, ist, was ich, und das ist vielleicht nur mein eigener Eindruck, das wirkt ja auf den ersten Blick wie so eine klassische NetzaktivistInnenaktion. Aber ich finde, es gibt was, was ist ein bisschen anders, weil es ging halt gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, da ging es sozusagen gegen ein konkretes Gesetz, ging gegen den Staatstrojaner, ging es auch klar gegen was Konkretes, gegen den Uploadfilter, gegen Netzwerken. Das waren alles so Themen, die hatten einen ganz konkreten, sehr eng fokussierten Angriffspunkt. Und ich finde, das ist hier ein bisschen anders, weil das ist ja eine Kampagne für etwas, also klar gegen Biometrieüberwachung, aber halt eben dafür zu sagen, hey Leute, es gibt hier ein Problemfeld, das ihr mal bearbeiten müsst. Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich, ist das wirklich so, oder ist das sozusagen nur was sehr Subtiles, was eigentlich keine Rolle spielt, und das ist eigentlich wie immer was ganz Klassisches, der Überwachungsstaat schafft Dinge, und dagegen muss man vorgehen. Macht das für euch, hat das für euch in der Arbeit irgendwie einen Unterschied gemacht, ist das eine neue Qualität, dass man jetzt quasi schon so ein bisschen vorneweg ist, auch klar, wenn es um eine Entwicklung geht, oder ist es genau dasselbe wie immer?
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass das nicht passiert. Also die Ankündigung, dass auf allen Flughäfen und großen Bahnhöfen Deutschland solche Kameraüberwachung installiert werden soll, die hat es ja gegeben. Dass es am Ende dann doch nicht in ein Gesetz gemündet ist, haben wir in dem Fall vermutlich der SPD zu verdanken, aber es war ja kurz davor. Also wir haben das ja, das ist wie mit der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, auch die Kameraüberwachung im öffentlichen Raum kommt wie so ein untoter Zombie immer wieder. Das heißt, jeder Zeitpunkt ist der richtige. Und ich muss eigentlich gar nicht warten darauf, dass wieder ein neues Gesetz in der Schublade ist, weil ich mir sowieso sicher sein kann, dass da eins in der Schublade ist. Und dann kann man, ich hab ja vorhin versucht zu beschreiben, jetzt ist eigentlich ein ganz geschickter Zeitpunkt. Und vielleicht ist es auch ganz gut, dass es noch in einer Schublade liegt und gerade nicht auf dem Tisch liegt, weil man es dann vielleicht verhindern kann. Und da wäre jetzt wirklich ein geschickter Moment, einerseits ein Moratorium auszuhandeln und eben noch besser ein Verbot zu erreichen gegen Massenüberwachung durch Gesichtserkennung.
Vielleicht mal kurz zu sagen, Moratorium heißt ein zeitlich eingeschränktes Verbot. Also nicht für immer, sondern 3 oder 5 Jahre sind, glaube ich, in der Spur.
Ja, erstmal, um überhaupt die Sache besser zu verstehen und näher zu untersuchen. Da hätte unser eins natürlich die Hoffnung, dass die Untersuchung dann ergeben hat, dass es weiterhin gar keinen Sinn macht. Aber das, was ja alle, also selbst konservativere Lager, eine bestimmte braune Partei schließlich da aus, sich einig sind, ist, dass sie sagen, wir wissen eigentlich noch viel zu wenig. Und da könnte man über diesen Hebel vielleicht als erstes Moratorium hinkriegen. Das Ziel sollte aber unbedingt sein, deswegen sollte man auch immer dieses Ziel kommunizieren, dass es ein Verbot staatlicher Massenüberwachung durch Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum gibt.
Okay, aber von der politischen Arbeit ist es dasselbe wie immer?
Für mich eigentlich schon, ja.
Es ist, ja, naja, also es ist natürlich ein, also, dass man früher dran ist, wie eigentlich schon immer, dass man sagt, kann man so Entwicklungen verhindern, aber es ist natürlich auch ein weniger klares Ziel, was manchmal vielleicht in der Kommunikation dann ein bisschen, man muss sich eher auf breitere Grundwerte beziehen, als zu sagen, das ist ein Gesetz, was wir verhindern müssen. In dem Sinne gibt es so minimale, würde ich schon sagen, in der tatsächlichen Überzeugungsarbeit. Also man muss so ein bisschen das Ziel klarer definieren, bisschen wertebasierter argumentieren, so in diese Richtung.
Aber es gibt ja auch Anwendungsfälle in Europa. Und das ist ja eine europäische Initiative. Und da fand ich ganz spannend, wer auf diese Seite mal raufgeht. Der kann sich ja auch angucken. Da gibt es immer so kleine Berichte zu irgendwas. Da wird dann erzählt, eine bestimmte Stadt in Polen hat sich auch entschieden, keine Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum mehr zu haben. In Frankreich wollten sie Gesichtserkennung an Schulen haben und mussten das wegen einer Aktion von Reclaim Your Face-Unterstützern wieder einstellen. Das sind ganz konkrete Beispiele, die irgendwo in Europa gerade stattfinden. Und die man sich dann als Anlass in der jeweiligen Region, im jeweiligen Land, rauspickt. Und diese eine Klammer über alles rüberlegt, was dann Gesichtserkennung in der Schule verbindet mit der Gesichtserkennung auf öffentlichen Bahnhöfen und vielleicht auch irgendwo an Supermärkten. Und dann eine gemeinsame Geschichte daraus macht anhand vieler verschiedener Beispiele. Also viele Puzzle, ein Gesamtbild.
Dann würde ich an dieser Stelle, glaube ich, zum Abschluss kommen wollen. Denn ich denke, wir haben genau das geschafft, was ich am Anfang versucht habe zu versprechen. Nämlich ein solides Basiswissen zum Thema Biometrie und Überwachung an öffentlichen Plätzen oder im öffentlichen Raum. Und dazu Hilfe von neuen Technologien zu machen. Vielen Dank euch, dass ihr alle hier wart. Hat noch jemand ein Famous Last Word? Ich kann das Gespräch gerne die Runde noch mal durchgeben. Rainer, möchtest du noch etwas zum Abschluss mitgeben? Den Menschen, die zuhören an den neuartigen Rundfunk-Ampfangsgeräten?
Ja, ich würde vielleicht noch sagen, dass dieses Verbannen oder dieses Stoppen der Videoüberwachung, das ist ja auch eine bestimmte Art von Technologie, die man braucht, um diese Plätze zu überwachen. Dass man immer auch mit denken muss, wenn das in Europa möglich ist, dann wird es auch hier eine Industrie geben, die genau diese Sachen herstellt. Und diese Industrie wird sich nicht nur mit einem EU-internen Geschäftsfeld zufrieden geben. D.h. da gibt es noch eine andere Sache, das kann man jetzt noch machen. Aber der Kram wird dann natürlich auch exportiert werden, rund um die Welt. Und das ist natürlich, ich finde, das ist auch ein Punkt, der mir sagen würde, es ist noch weiterer Grund, da einfach nicht in diese Richtung da einfach mitzumachen bei so einer Entwicklung.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, ich finde die Initiative Reclaim Your Face super. Ich hoffe auch, dass sie die Bubble verlässt. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, dass man gegen massenhafte Gesichtserkennung eigentlich nichts mehr tun kann. Und genau deswegen muss man was dagegen tun. Deswegen muss sie verboten werden.
Ja, da kann ich direkt anschließen. Ich habe nämlich Vorschläge, was man tun kann. Die haben natürlich mit meinem direkten Umfeld zu tun. Schreibt an Abgeordnete und zwar an zwei Typen von Abgeordneten. Schreibt an die, in deren Wahlkreis ihr wohnt, weil die interessieren sich für euch, die anderen nicht so sehr. Und schreibt an die, die Mitglied im Innenausschuss sind. Und zwar egal, in welchem Wahlkreis die aktiv sind. Und dann diese gleichen, denen könnt ihr entweder Briefe schreiben, ihr könnt auch die Büros anrufen, da erreicht man immer irgendjemand, könnt ihnen ein Öhrchen abkauen. Ihr könnt aber, und das ist fast noch besser, ihr könnt auch beides machen, diese MdBs über Abgeordneten-Watch anfragen. Keine Massenanfragen, die werden von Abgeordneten-Watch abgebogen, aber zum Beispiel die in eurem Wahlkreis. Die könnt ihr einfach konkret fragen, was ist eure Position zur Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum? Und natürlich schreibt ihr noch einen Dreizeiler dazu, warum ihr glaubt, dass es eine ganz schlechte Idee wäre, das zu machen. Und ihr könnt auch hingehen, wenn es jetzt im Demnächst ganz viele verschiedene Wahlveranstaltungen digital oder analog gibt, und fragt die einfach. Dann zwingt ihr nämlich auch die, die sich sonst mit Ferkelkastration beschäftigen, über dieses Thema nachzudenken und könnt auf diese Weise Aufklärung machen. Was dann nämlich passiert, wenn ich kriege zum Beispiel Briefe zu Ferkelkastration, ich komme immer wieder auf dieses sehr schöne Beispiel, ich frage dann unsere agrarpolitische Sprecherin und sage, oh, keine Ahnung, von Ferkel erzähl mal und dann schickt die mir da so ein Traktat und schon weiß ich ein bisschen besser als vorher Bescheid über diese Ferkelchen. Genau so würde das passieren, wenn ihr alle Briefe schreibt an diese Abgeordneten und denen erklärt, warum sie jetzt auch gegen diese Überwachung sein sollen. Und dann müssen die sich mit dem Thema beschäftigen. Ihr könnt ja auch reinschreiben, hört doch doch dieses Chaosradio an. Seitdem ihr das gehört habt, seid ihr total überzeugt davon. Schlechte Idee. Wenn die das anhören, sind sie bestimmt auch davon überzeugt. Vielleicht hört es ja dann mal einer von denen an.
Markus, du musst jetzt dieses Chaosradio selber in unsere Show Notes tun.
Okay, Chaosradioception. Und den Abschluss dieser Chaosradioception macht Matthias. Möchtest du auch noch ein letztes Wort an die Allgemeinheit richten?
Gerne. Also ich finde das natürlich auch sehr schön, wenn ihr eure VolksvertreterInnen anschreibt. Ihr könnt aber auch Firmen oder staatliche Behörden anschreiben und fragen, welche Daten sie über euch haben oder fragen, wie sie in der Öffentlichkeit überwachen, um dann Transparenz und eine gewisse Öffentlichkeit herzustellen.
So, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr habt was gelernt und ihr habt Hausaufgaben mitbekommen. Dabei wünsche ich viel Spaß. Vielen Dank, dass ihr dabei wart. Vielen Dank Rainer, Andrea, Anke, Matthias, dass ihr dabei wart und uns Zeit und Erklärungen hier gelassen habt. Danke dafür nochmal. Und ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle und mir bleibt am Ende der Sendung nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht biometrisch überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.